the Joe Rogan experience scale bro you
did it no way let's go hey I've got to
see what your I was trying to say this
earlier I remember I gotta piss alright
I remember doing a podcast it's and then
wait Joe I did a podcast with you at the
end of September beginning of October
and you looked like a [ __ ] junkie
like on the streets that's a pocket to
fat cows podcast yeah to fat cows dude
at the end of October
he looked transformed he looked transfer
yeah at the end of October yes it was
one month one month he looked for
everybody like purchase like he's
somebody who looked dramatically
different
blarp what are you wearing right now
what are you wearing I I weighed the
other day was to 232
what do you weigh around between 235 and
238 for what we're telling you the right
numbers yeah this Gail will tell us if
those are the right numbers or not just
weigh your foot right now come on I'll
tell you I think's [ __ ] do you want to
do a trust way how about this how about
this by the way Adam for this I rather
forced her off my special February 7th
4th show 10 10 o'clock show oh yeah ugh
he's gone why Charlotte Pittsburgh and
poor the main this is the branding at
the jute or how about this you ready for
this
what if Tom and I weigh in together yeah
and wait under 7,000 how about this if
Tom and I weigh under 500 ohms yeah you
you have to weigh in to fight advice 250
age no you're under way in the we would
definitely wonder 500 pounds
yeah we wait and you're 500 yeah
and offers full clothes on not peeing
hmm
yeah I'm sound 498 foreign no you you
have to wait in a 450 yeah we weigh over
450 over 450 together clear that be 25
buck and you don't we definitely way
over that oh yeah
475 30 booter 475 44 wasn't you weighing
in
Hey Joe what do you think Tom and I
weigh in together him on my back I said
7000 but you still have those tits Jesus
Joe you look like the dude from [ __ ]
guardians of the galaxy you wear the
underwear every guy who works out
are you gotta get off first are you
gonna get off Frank is your tap open in
the air you don't know look at your core
what is it jul 5 2013 10 time in like as
soon as a grown up this time period so
you think you were better shape when you
were younger
no you should see the [ __ ] Joe Rogan
headshot on the Commerce Tour wall he's
a hundred and forty pound weakling
[Laughter]
[Applause]